a bunch of people started tweeting me  have you seen this article is it true  Allison says the company put out this  fake tweet from her claiming the  supplement was the reason some of the  Biggest Loser contestants lost weight  bottom line is one of the best things I  learned at the Biggest Loser is how  important health is and how important it  is to eat right and workout and that  there are no shortcuts  once heavier herself she lost a weight  through diet and exercise she went on  the offensive against what she calls  fraudulent advertising through Facebook  what you are seeing here is a form of  identity theft how are you gonna correct  the situation and is this company still  using your likeness yeah we still see it  on social media boy you've sent a  cease-and-desist letter you know I have  lawyers involved and we're getting  involved in litigation we're gonna do  what we have to to stop them their  internet trolls and people need to  unfortunately be really careful